welcome everyone to this meeting of the
council i am councillor james caston
chairman of mid-suffolk district council
and i will be chairing this meeting
today
may i first remind you all of some
domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs cold water is also
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room by following the fire exit signs
and meet on the ipswich town football
club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it's safe to do so
please switch all laptops and mobile
phones onto silent
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you are
also consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members the council members
of the public and the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and the press
are not lawfully excluded
and i'll move to the agenda
first item on the agenda is apologies
for absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from councillors
carter hattingham phillips and scarf and
pratt
i'll i'll take this opportunity to
say that councillor pratt
recently had a
son
and we all wish him well
on behalf of mid suffolk district
council
[Applause]
and um
i think
i'm very happy for him and um it'll be
good to see him here again soon
right so um
item two is declarations of interest by
the councillors
so um please note that the monitoring
officer has granted dispensations to the
directors of the council's companies so
are there any other declarations of
interest
no
thank you item three
mc2211 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 23rd of june 2022
for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
no
could have a proposal
councillor flatman
and a seconder
councillor geek
so what we'll do with this is we'll show
hands
for approval of the minutes so um all
those in favor
so that's carried thank you
item four the chairman's announcement i
refer you to paper mc2212 for noting
please note that i was unable to attend
the ipswich mayor's at home
as um i had already begun work on the
farm
for harvest
so thank you
and on to item five the leaders
announcement i'd like to invite
councillor morley to present her update
any points of clarification
can be raised afterwards but we will
stick to points of clarification
not questions on anything else
thank you councillor morley
thank you thank you chair
and it's been a relatively short period
of time since our last full council
meeting and so i've focused my
announcements this month on our recent
successes
however i do want to start by praising
our emergency services
and in particular the suffolk fire
service who have been under such
pressure have been so fantastic during
this recent spell of extreme heat
it has been a busy few weeks of
significant milestones for our companies
and council projects
with the range being confirmed as the
first occupier at gateway 14
and completion of the first phase of 32
new homes
and a new co-op store at chambers green
in needham market
a further 60 homes will follow as part
of phase 2 which is expected to start
later in the year
cabinet have also agreed to fund the
development of detailed designs and
public engagement
for a potential new well-being and
leisure hub for mid-suffolk
the project will provide new and
improved facilities for a wide range of
sports leisure and health organizations
all brought together across a single
site in stone market
the hot weather has coincided with the
start of school summer holidays and i'm
really proud that we are able to provide
alongside our partners an array of
activities
explore outdoor will again be getting
children out and about in nature while
kinetic science will be encouraging
children to learn through fun with some
hands-on experiments
there will also be a variety of cooking
lessons provided by the food museum
outdoor explore outdoor and ebenham
sports and leisure centre all supporting
our ambition to combat holiday hunger
there will also be sessions for swimming
football arts and crafts dodge ball and
film making workshops
and free places are available for all of
the activities for those most in need
we're all continuing to tackle issues in
relation to housing and homelessness
through our newly adopted empty homes
policy we will be reducing the number of
long-term empty properties in
mid-suffolk
this includes our empty homes renovation
loan
this is an interest-free loan of up to
twenty thousand pounds to help owners to
renovate
properties that have been empty for more
than six months
i'm also really pleased that alongside
council hicks and councillor passmore as
part of the suffolk public sector
leaders group we've been able to create
a new climate change fund
the 150 000 pounds suffolk climate
action community match fund is available
for all not-for-profit organizations
looking to deliver community-based
carbon reduction product
projects these could include improving
the energy efficiency of buildings
promoting walking and cycling
using sustainable recycled materials and
raising awareness of climate change
through events
ahead to later in the year
our second innovation awards has been
launched
the awards are a celebration of all
types of innovation across businesses in
all sectors
it showcases how our businesses are
using innovative approaches to deliver
their products and services
ranging from customer services to new
technologies
there are ten categories across a range
of sectors that celebrate the best of
innovation in the high street health
care construction customer service and
foods
and there are also awards for young
innovators
innovation in future technology and the
business innovator of the year
awards
application awards
sorry applications for the awards close
on the 14th of august so please do
encourage and support the business in
your awards to get involved
i want to take the opportunity to
mention the local government association
peer review report which has just been
published on our website
the report describes how we are punching
above our weight and praises our
ambition and delivery
however we will not rest on our laurels
as we all want to be even better and to
keep improving our services and the
quality of life for all our residents
this has never been more important given
the cost of living crisis and climate
emergency
and alongside the report we have
therefore published an action plan based
upon the peer reviews recommendations
and finally i want to confirm the
changes i've made to cabinet
and welcome some new colleagues to the
senior leadership team
as you will be aware councillor harry
richardson has taken over from
councillor gerard brewster as deputy
leader of the council
harry has also become the portfolio
holder for economy and councillor julie
flatman will be both portfolio holder
for communities and also for well-being
gerard remains on cabinet without a
portfolio
i'm really grateful to gerard for his
support both as deputy leader and
portfolio holder
and i'm sure you will all join me in
sending our best wishes to gerard's
family
as councillors know we are currently
recruiting to three roles within the
senior leadership team
in the interim we have appointed
temporary support for all three roles
so i would like to welcome
anita
kikuli as director of operations and die
robinson as director of communities and
well-being
chris stratford will be also be joining
us during august as director of housing
and interviews for the permanent
appointments to these roles will be
happening in early early september
thank you everybody
thank you councillor morley
so on to item six to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with council procedure rules
thank you chair none received
item seven questions by the public in
accordance with the council procedurals
received
and eight questions by councillors in
accordance with council procedure rules
none received here
so we move on to item nine
mc2213 capital investment fund company
cifco capital limited business trading
and performance report
2021-2022 and business plan
i would like to invite councillor gould
to update the council on this item
councillor gould
thank you very much uh chair
i have withdrawn the cifco business plan
from tonight's agenda following the
cancellation of the babra uh council
meeting earlier this week
it will be rescheduled to be considered
by both councils uh shareholders in
september
september meetings
whilst this is unfortunate i am pleased
uh that the joint overview and scrutiny
committee
had an opportunity to publicly
scrutinize
the business plan last month
and that the committee confirmed
that it was satisfied with the plan and
the performance of cifco
councillors may also recall that the
civic business plan was deferred in the
september council meeting to the
september council meetings last year uh
due to the pandemic
and that was without significant impact
a redacted copy of the business plan and
the covering report has been published
and should counselors have any queries
prior to september then please do let me
know in due course thank you chad
thank you councillor gould
so that takes us on to item 10.
i'm not taking questions on this
sorry
um item 10
mc2214
gateway 14 limited extension to peak
loan facility
i would like to invite councillor gould
to introduce paper
mc2214 and to move recommendations in
the report
councillor gould okay thank you uh very
much uh cane chair uh i'm delighted to
be presenting this report to the council
today at a time when significant
progress is being made
at gateway 14 in stone market
the infrastructure works
started on site in april
and are progressing well
with the future shape of the business
part being revealed more each day
gateway 14 limited is also recently
announced the first occupier for the
site
the range one of the fastest growing
retailers uh in the uk
gateway 14 will deliver a breen
excellent
high quality distribution center for the
range creating 1 650
new jobs
this is a significant investment for the
range and it's integral to
their expansion plans
this first occupier aligns well with
gateway 14 and freeport east aspirations
for development delivering sustainable
high quality buildings and jobs
in december 2020 the council approved
the total development funding of 37.9
million to deliver the development of
gateway 14.
this budget assumed
infrastructure costs of 16.2 million
and a delivery over 12 to 15 year period
now since that date
two key factors have come into play
the first
is the
considerable cost inflation in the
construction market due to the pandemic
to brexit and the war in ukraine
the second factor which
can be considered a positive is the need
to accelerate delivery given the
immensely strong interest in the
development and given the time scales
associated with
pre-port east
now the purpose of this report
is because additional funding is needed
to complete the infrastructure works as
a single phase and to simultaneously
progress other stages of the development
such as reserve matches planning
application for the range
the options to rephase the
infrastructure works and alternative
funding sources are set out within
section two of the report and those are
represented full consideration
of the options
uh i do hope that and expect the council
will approve the recommended option to
increase the peak debt threshold as this
is the only option
that does not
interrupt or delay the continuing
progress at gateway 14 and i commend it
to you
we have here see the director of assets
and investment and possibly
online uh sir christopher howarth i
don't know whether that's
maybe oh both both of those will be
or one at least will be delighted to
assist with any questions that
counselors have thank you very
much
thank you councillor gould could i get a
seconder for that councillor brewster
and also i will
reserve my right to speak at the end
thank you
thank you councillor brewster
and we will now move to questions
whilst councillors can ask as many
questions as they like i would prefer
if they kept to the three questions
and keep them as blunt and as to the
point
as they possibly can so we can move
through to debate
thank you very much i'll take questions
now
councillor stringer
thank you chair uh
thank you peter uh just a question on
5.1
it says that the range anticipates
650 jobs in the region in our press
releases and other press statements it
suggests there's a similar number of
jobs
this will bring about on gateway 14.
could we please clarify the statement uh
is this number of jobs going to be
on the on the range at gateway 14 or in
the region because obviously the two are
a larger geographical area
to address that thank you
the director for assets and investments
uh thank you councillors for that
question i can confirm the
1650 jobs will be at gateway 14
so it's my style of writing that's
probably caused that confusion in the
report so i apologize for that
then share with your intelligence could
we amend the report to accurately
reflect the correct position
thank you
councillor ebern
thank you very much chair
and thank you for the report um
just with regards to the overall amount
um being um asked for here
it implies in the report that it isn't
dependent on on the range being um on
this site but i just wondered if one
firstly we could have absolute clarity
of that
that the
us if we would approve this peak debt
facility the increase in that that it
isn't dependent on having a
um
[Music]
a business that's already signed up for
the for the site and secondly um also
could we just confirm
what the basis is that the range are now
signed up for if that's a
written contract or if it's something
that's got that they could potentially
change if needs be just to give us some
um certainty thank you very much
thank
thank you i suspect
the latter point there may be some
commercial uh caution to be applied but
um again i'll ask the director to to
address
the director for assets and investments
thank you councillor for that question
um so in relation to
um the
contracts with the range yes i can
confirm that contracts have been
exchanged they're conditional contracts
but the conditions are
based on the performance of gateway 14
so the range doesn't have the ability to
walk away so for instance the gateway 14
needs to secure
the detailed planning consent for the
delivery of the new facility
and i'm really sorry i've forgotten your
first question
thank you it was just in terms of um
just to confirm or to clarify that the
what we're agreeing today or potentially
agreeing today is not dependent on the
range being
part of the deal
thank you
yes it is to confirm that the additional
funds are required regardless of whether
the range proceeds or not and so the
report is
phrased with recommendations so there's
no interdependency with the range
transaction
thank you council field
thank you i just wanted to ask you a
couple of questions about the paper
marks confidential is that
give us problems or
not
we um we can go into closed session if
you um do you really need to um i i
wanted to refer to sort of
direction of change of numbers i don't
want to refer necessarily to the figures
themselves
right
if you ask the question without giving
them details then
the director for assets and investment
investments can decide whether that
needs to go into closed session but we
do want to try to do everything in the
open if we can i understand that
obviously i support that uh it was
merely that the
the numbers for utilities seem to
have increased quite dramatically
and the numbers for highways
issues have gone down substantially and
yet both seem to be impacted by the same
set of
issues that were mentioned in the main
paper the
brexit costs and all the rest of it so i
just it seems somewhat strange
could you explain that
thank you councillor field you did very
well there and the director for assets
and investments
thank you so i can answer that in in
general terms in in open session
and so the budget was set in 2020 it was
an indicative budget and we have since
2020 undertaken much more detailed due
diligence which has led to some
increases in costs for specific reasons
and with regard to utilities and some
reduction in costs in terms of highways
so the the general answer is to do with
the difference between setting budgets
at a fairly early stage in a project
against um
more detailed budgets once that detailed
due diligence has been completed i'm
more than happy in closed session to
explain a little bit more around that
but i don't think it would be
appropriate to do so in open session or
indeed if you'd like to have a
conversation outside this meeting
i'd be more than happy to share further
details as well
thank you for coming i don't think it's
necessary to go into more detail it
would be good if the the reasons you
just mentioned were recorded in the main
document as as part of the reason for
change
thank you and any further questions
council of war boys
no excuse me sitting down i've sort of
come unplugged otherwise
um
yeah just
um the great the range has on its
website sort of um
uh claims for of
how it's working towards meeting uh
climate change um we have got quite
specific
um
[Music]
targets for gateway 14 with regard to
meeting
um
the climate crisis net zero
uh has the contract has sort of been
signed and is perhaps conditional
is it fully compliant with our
our own set of environmental standards
director assets and investments
thank you councillor um so we've been
really um pleased to work with the range
um in regard to their the first occupier
of gateway 14 because they share our
aspirations
with regard to delivering a highly
sustainable building
and we are working together to achieve
more than our
requirements as we've set out and so
um
i suppose in answer yes we will have
exceeded our basic um threshold in terms
of what we will deliver
from an environmental perspective in the
delivery of this building
and we're exploring currently how we can
go even further
in that regard
thank you very much and that's the end
of questions so
we'll now move to the debate um
councillors will only be allowed to
speak once and for three minutes
um that we will be time in this so who
would like to go first
councillor ebern
someone needs to start thank you chair
um
firstly i'd like to say that and i've
always supported um gateway 14 because
i'm very pleased that we're investing in
our local area
and that that investment will be um
it will impact our local residents in
lots of different ways so from the
actual investment from jobs they might
get and and so on and so forth
so
just to say up front that i will be
supporting um this recommendation
and
and also i i would like to just thank
the um assistant director for her work
on this especially in um bringing
forward um a um
company to to become the first one on on
this side because i think you obviously
need one for all others to follow as it
were
but i would like to say that you know
there is work going on and you know
obviously continually going on and i
think it's very very important that that
work pushes as far and as fast as
possible especially in terms of the
environmental credentials this is a site
that we own we need it to be as exemplar
as possible we need to show others what
we can do and we need to ensure that in
terms of all of the um
elements of it and from everything that
all the sustainable bit whether we can
generate
power for those organizations on it
through solar panels and so forth
making sure that it's
we're improving the biodiversity on that
site so that local residents when it's
obviously there's going to be a stage of
building works which is going to be
cause disruption for an awful lot of
people but that the end result will be
something that is is better and is
really worthwhile
so i would just urge that we really push
and keep pushing um to make it the best
it can thank you chair
thank you councillor passmore
thank you very much chairman um i have
no problem with the tournament
supporting this i think it's an
excellent development and the sooner we
can push it forward with great speed
because we're all aware of some other
fairly major infrastructure projects
elsewhere in the county that will be
taking place fairly soon and i say that
in all seriousness because the pressure
it will put on construction and so on
is going to clearly increase the other
thing is i think it will act as a magnet
for greater prosperity not just for us
here in in mid-suffolk because of its
leak to the freeport which i think has
got enormous potential and we need to
get our shoulders well and truly fair
and square behind the wheel and get on
and give it a large shove so that we can
actually get that inward investment
expand the um tax base and the economic
growth we've got as much as possible but
of course and i do agree with rachel
there done in the right way with the
right credentials so it's something we
are all proud of fit for purpose to the
future and that was one of the things we
certainly discussed in detail at our
planning committee meeting um a few
months ago i think it is now so uh more
powerful available elbow so let's just
get on with it thank you
thank you councillor passmore
any further comments
all right okay um councillor gould would
you like to add anything
just uh very briefly yeah if i may chair
uh and and to thank uh colleagues for
for the positive comments uh
that have been made yes the whole
intention as i said in my introduction
is to enable us to uh press on
with this to meet to meet the demand and
i think casa passmore makes a very good
point about what will be growing demand
within within this county for the uh for
construction resources to push ahead
with major infrastructure projects i
think that's a point uh that is is well
made
uh
thanks to cassie bourne for her for her
points i would i would mention that
um
emily along with her peers are now quite
properly described as directors uh i
think that's that's entirely right uh so
to just to a minor point of
of correction
i think one of the things that since i
took over this portfolio uh has been
come increasingly apparent to me is the
convergence between
commercial success and environmental
interest and we see this or at one point
you know we might have thought that
these two are somehow intentioned but
increasingly they come to the same thing
and what is being said about the range
absolutely demonstrates this that there
they recognize their long-term uh
commercial success uh rests on their
ability to deliver on low-carbon and
environmental agenda so
thank you to colleagues for their
comments i hope that now translates into
a positive vote
as per the recommendation thank you very
much
thank you councillor gould
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
blue for councillors to cast their vote
thank you chairman
um
this is a a fairly complex um
paper uh it's got a lot in it
and um
i would like first of all to thank
christine thurlow for all the work she
and her team have put into
carrying out
this review and to documenting
everything i also i think on this
occasion need to thank my
baba counterpart
who has
taken the opportunity to
slightly condense
the the opening remarks
which are still nonetheless extensive
but i do thank uh
councillor arty for he doesn't know that
i'm using this particular version but uh
i'm sure he'll
i'm sure he won't mind
anyway uh
the the sill expenditure framework and
communication strategy
were originally agreed and adopted by
both councils in march 2018.
there have been annual reviews by the
joint member panel which have led to
changes being adopted to the sill
expenditure framework and communication
strategy in march 2019 april 2020 and
march 2021.
it was also agreed that a further review
would take place this year
the report in front of you today is a
result of that work
undertaken by the cross council cross
party joint member panel
the proposed changes are listed in full
in paragraph 4.5 of the report but i
will highlight the main points
at first
there are changes regarding eligibility
for infrastructure
which reduces the carbon footprint
including district parish heating
systems for communal buildings within
parishes
currently ev charging points are
supported for 100 of the project costs
however now suggested that it should be
up to a hundred percent accepting that
other funding may be available and that
carbon reduction heating systems should
be eligible for district sale funding
where there are improvements or upgrades
or additional additionality in community
buildings but not for repair or
maintenance
next
there's increased clarity around sale
bids from organizations that change the
charge admittance
we will continue to fund infrastructure
projects
for museums
but we will not fund public open space
and place-based projects
if an
admittance fee is charged we believe
such facilities should be capable of
being used by all without charge
next we have changes to the project
inquiry forms which aid project
development
and amongst the improvements to the
website we want to include maps of both
districts showing locations of completed
sill projects along with details and
before and after pictures
we
expect consistent arrangements for use
of ring fence monies using suggested
catchment areas for proposed
infrastructures
infrastructure for schools rail and
health hubs
where infrastructure delivery is
proposed through the submission of
silvids the financing of these bids when
recommended to cabinet or through
delegated decisions
will be undertaken by using ring fence
monies first
supplemented by the use of strategic or
local infrastructure funds secondly if
necessary
we've reviewed the current 75 000 pound
threshold and 75 percent of total costs
for sale bids submitted by the community
and we're proposing that this should
increase to a hundred thousand and
seventy five percent of total cost of
the project to address rising
infrastructure and materials costs
next comes funding for cycling and
footpaths
projects in the lc whip idp and ifs
we're suggesting here
a pilot period of schemes
with the new community threshold of a
hundred thousand pounds and proactive
work to bring
lc whip schemes forwards with the
outcomes informing the next review
we want to encourage greater spending of
sill including neighborhoods civil
we want to continue with current
proactive approaches towards expenditure
and progression of sil bids and
in addition
produce capital project work plans for
the next five years
with other infrastructure providers such
as health
and suffolk county county waste
to county council waste to address
infrastructure priorities
we will monitor
alongside the ifs where neighborhood
sales spend is occurring and if
necessary carry out focused discussion
with the parish about capital sill
projects that are underway
we will offer targeted website advice
with specific guidance
note to aid project development and
development of pips parish
parish investment infrastructure plans
and we will look to the use of
neighbourhood sale on a case-by-case
basis and monitor this for the next
review of the sill expenditure framework
we agreed to keep the sill expenditure
framework under review i've mentioned
how some of our proposals will feed into
the next review
and we are suggesting another still
expenditure framework review the fifth
should occur whilst bid round 10 is
underway in october 2022 so that any
revisions are adopted before bit round
11 occurs in may 2023
now moving on to the sill expenditure
framework communication strategy which
you'll find at appendix b
we will continue with regular briefing
sessions for members and parish councils
in line with the requirement
of the communication strategy
but increase the number of events from
two to three each year with members also
being invited to the parish events so
that they can accompany their parishes
if they wish
and i refer you to paragraph 4.6 of the
report on this
and finally that the joint member panel
remains in place to inform the fifth
still expensive framework review
um so here i'm proposing the
recommendations of paragraph three which
i won't read out to you
but um
i i will look for a second thank you
thank you councillor burn do i have a
secondary council of flatman
thank you councillor flatman will now
move to questions who would like to
start or
count councillor
um
sorry
thank you
just a question about the engagement and
briefings with local people
i wonder if it would be a good idea to
invite village hall
committees um and the like to
these briefings not just the parish
council because quite often parish
councils are
i
wouldn't say a law to themselves but
they're not always the best way to get
information out to the parish
particularly if it's a village a village
hall committee or a community group so i
just wondered if the invitations could
be broadened of it
thank you councillor byrne
uh well um thank you councillor william
um
as this is cross party of course we need
to refer that to um
sorry not cross party cross cross
council as well
we would want to refer that to to
my baby counterpart but i can't see any
objection to that counselor well uh i
think it's a good idea you're absolutely
right the parish council are not always
the best medium for for transmitting
information through through to the
community but may i ask i mean we've got
christine further here um who
on on any matters of detail uh or any
matters at all for that matter
is is a a greater expert than i am so
could i ask her to make comment on that
please christine thank you thank you
um in practice when we've been dealing
with uh infrastructure led by the
community we're increasingly finding
that we are dealing uh with
more organizations uh than just the
parish council and we have widened
our scope in order to make sure that we
have included
others so i'm sure that will be
appropriate and it is actually what what
has been happening in practice
thank you thank you councillor rotten
uh thank you um yes i was interested to
read at paragraph
38
spending outside each council's
geographical area
is acceptable
so i'd like a bit of an explanation on
that a bit
but also
the reverse of that
is there a possibility
that neighbouring councils
i know not all of them do have
seal
we'll be able to actually we would be
able to access money from neighbouring
councils
my other question is
where it says
maintenance
is not
eligible
but will there would there be
a conversation about that because it may
well be
if a village hall for example
boilers packed up
that would and they want to replace it
with an air source or something similar
i wouldn't classify that as maintenance
i would classify that as a new project
and just being slightly pedantic
somewhere here it says
churches are
where did i see that christine
churches are
eligible for sil
um
i'm not
aware
that we have a significant yeah there it
is 33
a significant number
of other if you like religious buildings
in the district but i think we should
not feel
that they are they would be excluded so
i think we need to slightly reword that
thank you
that's to the professional lead key
sites and infrastructure
please
thank you uh yes um in table two of the
sill expenditure framework that sets out
the parameters against which
spend outside of geographical boundaries
of favour and mid-suffolk can happen
subject to certain criteria and that's
all about the fact that if we are
spending outside of our boundary we
don't expect to pay
for all the infrastructure but we will
do collaborative spend proportionate all
the things that you would
expect to see and answering the the
first question uh yes we do think it's a
two-way street
and that we should be able to start
conversations and we have done both with
ipswich borough and with
west suffolk
about infrastructure which we feel
could well be put under pressure in our
respective districts where growth is
happening close to the boundary and
thurston rail is is one example of that
and conversations
are happening now
in terms of repair and maintenance the
reason why this has been ruled out from
the sill expenditure framework is simply
because we collect
sill for new growth and we need to be
able to address the infrastructure that
comes with servicing that new growth so
it was
a key principle that was
put in place it doesn't rule out
tangible tan can't say that tangible
betterment or additionality
so in the scenario uh the councillor
mentioned
if you were doing something which was a
betterment or it had additionality by
going from
an old boiler old style to something
which was greener then that would be
something that would be classed as
eligible
for sil
and i think the last point was about
churches and it was something that the
joint member panel at one of the reviews
debated in detail and felt that churches
should not be excluded
from the proposal and we did have an
ambitious project not in
mid-suffolk but in babur where there was
a failing village hall and they brought
part of their church that needed
an upgrade
into better use and now the community
use
that church rather than the failing
village hall the reason that the village
hall was failing was because the floor
could not be
walked on
uh and it was unsafe
respect christine that's not i
understand that but what i'm saying is i
think the wording should say something
like religious
buildings
you know as a pope because churches
implies that it was
church of england or whatever i know we
probably don't have a you know
other but there may well be
other instances thank you
thank you
councillor mansell
uh thank you chair um i've got a couple
of uh questions and i'm not sure if the
second one might
be more related to our next item but
they do sort of overlap
my first question is about the um
infrastructure delivery plan or
infrastructure list or whatever happens
to be called
because i noticed in the report it says
we're going to review
the spend on the funding statement and
the delivery plan
alongside how things are going now that
delivery plan is dated 2020 and i
wondered
when how and if it gets reviewed and
whether we have whether we influence
what
goes on that infrastructure list that
was my first question
the other question is about the
potential
for the pilot schemes on the lc whip to
receive some still funding which is why
i'm not sure if it's in the goes against
the next item or not
and we talk about some proactive working
on some pilot schemes
to get the lc whip
getting some results which i think is
fantastic but i i'm a bit concerned
about whether we have enough resource to
do that pro action
or whether we are relying on parishes
and other groups to come forward with
their uh
the schemes they'd like to be in our
pilot project for sale funding
thank you
and if that second question is more on
on the next item agenda i'm quite happy
to
do it again then
thank you and that's to the professional
lead key sites and infrastructure and
i'll let you deal with the second
question and how you please
thank you
the infrastructure delivery plan and the
infrastructure list which is part of the
infrastructure funding statement they
are inextricably linked we have started
work on an update to this at present
and we are walking forward with that
with our infrastructure providers
and with all the people that we normally
liaise with
i think you picked up i think i picked
up the fact that you were asking can you
infil influence i can't pronounce my
words today sorry
can you influence what is on the list i
think i have to emphasize that in both
cases
um
they are
evidence-based documents which come
forward
looking at growth and trying to
understand what capacity there is in the
system to support the infrastructure and
what we need to do about that in order
to make sure that we have the right
amount of school extensions
the right amount of projects for waste
that will deal with the consequence of
doing growth
in both documents we do have a provision
in there that says for community-led
development we will allow those to be
brought forward in the way that the sill
expenditure framework allows us to do
but i i do have to stress that uh
influencing projects when it's based on
evidence linked to growth proposals is
probably not something that you know we
can easily do
uh in terms of uh the cycling and
walking
uh initiative the
joint member panel were very keen
to put forward
a measure which would allow us to bring
forward some costed schemes
understand better than the methodology
for how we deal with that to get some of
the the schemes which have been
identified through both councils lc
whips
out and
done
and we have
i am working collaboratively
with our sustainable officer catherine
in terms of looking at what can be
brought forward and we've been
discussing how we achieved that
for schemes which are very close to
ipswich with that modal shift project
and how we take that forward so that
work is already
happening but it is a pilot arrangement
and we are expecting to bring back the
results of that to the joint member
panel to see how we're doing
thank you
thank you council oh would you like to
come back councilman could i just come
come back on that um uh thank you for
your answer um and uh on the subject of
the elsi whip uh pilot projects that
you're looking at on the soviet switch
fringe um are the members of the wards
involved being informed about that
that there they've got some schemes
within their area that are being brought
forward as pilot schemes thank you
thank you
there is one scheme that we are working
on uh in respect of weber where we are
already engaged with a community group
and they are aware that we are trying to
bring that scheme forward and that
is one of the pilot schemes that we're
looking at in the ipswich modal shift
project so yes we are doing that
are there any in mid suffolk
we're certainly looking forward uh to
bringing forward some schemes for
mid-suffolk we we have the lc whip for
both
uh areas and we will be just selecting
some projects to bring forward with both
councils and as you know we're already
fully and heavily engaged with suffolk
county council in terms of woolpit and
elmswell and the the walking and cycling
initiative to to link them both
thank you
thank you very much um there's
councillor eber and if there's some no
further questions after councillor even
we'll move on to debate
um thank you very much chair um i've got
two questions if i may um
firstly on page 121 um towards the
bottom we refer to the need for
getting quotes and the time frame for
which a quote can be held and the
reviewer suggested we shorten that from
six months to four months
a project in my ward the builder has
said we will hold a valid quote for 14
days
so that four months i'm sorry is no good
so could you
please advise what will happen in that
instance and can we have some kind of
thing where they're saying
um
a contingency or something because you
know as we refer to on the previous
items apply across construction costs
and so on are just going up all the time
and they can't keep them for four months
thank you
my second question
is that according to the council's
developer database we've currently got
18.8
million pounds sat in the strategic sill
pot
and i'm wondering if within the
communications we could just put out
more information about what that 18
million is going to be spent on in the
future because i think parishes and and
so on are keen to see that when they
have development in their areas that
money is accumulating and they're keen
to see how that's being spent not what
it's been spent on past but what it is
going to be spent on because obviously
they're getting the development right
now thank you chair
thank you and that's to the professional
lead key sites and infrastructure thank
you thank you as far as the four-month
quote is concerned yes i would entirely
agree at the moment with rising
infrastructure costs and material costs
then holding any quotes for any
extended period of time is not going to
happen so what we've agreed to do in
terms of practice
is to
update quotes as we go forward with the
assessment
of projects and to check in
as one of the last things that we would
do before we bring any sort of project
before cabinet for cabinet to consider
so that we do
have a timely and most updated
uh quote
in terms of uh
how will we approach uh infrastructure
going forward yes we do have
uh money in mid-suffolk in the the order
that you've
stated
you you'll see in your papers that we
are talking about getting five-year work
plans together with all of our
infrastructure uh providers which is
is uh quite a bold move but it will
allow us to budget and forecast and make
sure that we can afford
the infrastructure coming forward
there are waste projects that we are
talking about which are in the order of
three to five million we already have a
rail project that we're working on
which will be much much more than that
so
when you are talking about the
the big ticket items from an
infrastructure point of view they are
very costly
um i had a count up the other day and i
think there were 45
emerging projects for mid-suffolk which
ranged from projects within our own
district to
cross boundary projects to community
projects as well as working with our
infrastructure providers
so
yes i think we will have a plan going
forward about how that money is spent
and we we also uh want to be talking to
our parishes about
how they can contribute and help make
those schemes come forward
thank you
thank you very much councillor mellon
yeah thank you chad
just a single question this agenda item
applies across the two districts and we
are discussing it
i'm not sure if that's um
yeah and i'll
pass over to the
proof
yeah i pass that over to the
professional lead key sites and
infrastructure
thank you
obviously the the meeting at baber
didn't take place uh but we are
considering the still expenditure
framework results of the fourth review
tonight i understand that the the next
time
weber can consider
uh the fourth review
uh results will actually be on the 20th
of september
i've thought about this hard and we are
going to do a workaround with
baber bids in that we will take forward
any need to enhance
community bids as acceptable exceptions
to the current framework
and by considering this tonight it gives
the team and i
a lot more confidence about how we can
take forward existing bids that we had
in the last bid round in may which are
still as yet undetermined
and i believe we had 14 of those and we
also have a few more on top so
cabinet is we are going to cabinet on in
september for both councils
and we will then be going to cabinet
again in november to try and catch up
with uh whatever bids
we have that need a bit more development
in order to be taken through thank you
thank you um a question from councillor
whitehead
yeah sorry this is really a question for
clarification and i thought for a moment
actually that council mellon was going
to ask it but my question is can we as
mid suffolk
valley vote on a recommendation that
reads that babe admit suffolk agree or
beyblade suffolk approve it seems to me
that it should should not include both
councils names in there
pass you over to the monitoring officer
thank you chair and for the voting
tonight we will be voting for mid
suffolk if there was a need for babies
schemes to come forward earlier we could
of course use our urgent provisions for
decisions out of meetings to take that
but you are your own sovereign council
so you will be approving your bids
tonight
thank you very much and council of war
boys
uh
thank you councilman for your
introduction to the uh the explanation
very briefly you mentioned the
pips um
i think some clarification is needed for
parish councils with
how
parish infrastructure plans
relate to the sil
bids
um i find my price council almost
getting into a chicken and next
situation where they can't
make the sale bid because they don't
possess the pip
um
and
one
doesn't necessarily precede the other
the the parish infrastructure plan
developed in the course of preparing the
infrastructure bid so
i'd appreciate some clarification to
parish councils about the relevance and
the significance
of an existing parish infrastructure
plan
or whether that could be
identified in the course of preparing a
seal bid
yeah i'll do my best and of course i
will refer
the detail of that to to to christine if
i may um
but
am i right christine that
in order to make a bid for facil
the actual um
content of that does not have to have to
have been part of a paris infrastructure
plan in the first place that it's the
the parish infrastructure plan
is is a is a bit of a wish list but it
doesn't stop a different item coming up
um at the drop of a hat that isn't on
the uh on the pip but but yet it doesn't
preclude it being uh uh
asked for or or um
requested as a sill application
exactly but i think this needs to be
really
stressed to parish councils because you
see the pip
as in the context of a syllabid and
think we haven't they look around what's
up i think um council of war boys if i
move to debate now sorry
if you want to make that point in debate
you can be first on the list for debate
because
we are strain into debate
so um if we if we call that the end to
the of the questions and we'll move into
debate who would like to um start
okay well i think i think just just to
sort of try and continue also saying is
that
the
the significance of the pip needs a lack
of significance of the pit really needs
to be stressed to parish councils
in the course of the
inviting applications for sealed bids
um
with that that sort of
recommendation is like in your
communications of parish councils i'd be
very happy to support
your
proposal
thank you
thank you councillor stringer
thank you chair just wanted to uh uh as
part of the debate just sort of
amplify the issue about there being two
councils in the
in the proposal that that surely cannot
legally be correct
because
if we if we agree to say yes we're
agreeing that baber
should agree this framework i've not
been elected to baber no one in this
room has so we should not speak on
behalf of that council and incidentally
if they were to reject this are they
rejecting it on mid-suffolk's behalf
against our wishes which i hope will
agree today so i think there's an
element of housekeeping i would
certainly like to see amended before i
say yes to this
just want to thank the team for
as it were the sort of working end of
the sill arrangements the sort of sharp
end of it thank you for the work you do
it is an immensely complex area and i'm
always impressed with the detail and and
how all this stuff gets built together
and sometimes how uh
the rules are interpreted and and to
meet sometimes really crushingly tight
deadlines to deliver some of these
schemes that sometimes change almost at
the last minute so
thank you for that i'll certainly be
voting for this
uh but can i just make a plea to those
sitting on the benches opposite
you're about to have a vote in a
different chamber uh about government
policy
and while government's quite fluid and
making all sorts of promises at the
moment can i just make a little bit of a
plea that you use
all of the uh all of the
political strength you've got
to actually look at the front end of the
seal charging framework and get the
government to amend it
because frankly within a few hundred
yards of where i live there are
40 market homes about to be built and
they will all pay sill
but there's 20 affordables on that site
that won't pay a penny
on top of the 20
self-build homes that are around me that
also haven't paid a penny now i can't
understand
how
only the 40 market homes will generate
the need for payment for infrastructure
that the other 40 homes won't generate
the demand for because i know pretty
much well that those affordable homes
and those self-build homes will generate
the need for play equipment and all that
infrastructure
so i'm not suggesting they pay perhaps
the same amount perhaps it could be a
different amount but i still think the
principle should be if this is a
development tax which frankly that's
what it is it should then be a
development tax and lot people not like
just some people of 100
because it does actually skew some of
the figures and it might mean that if
more people contributed the overall
figure could actually be less and
promote more sustainable growth thank
you
thank you councillor stringer and we'll
just go to the corporate manager
governance and civic office for an
update on something that's come up thank
you chair so just for clarity um tonight
you will be voting that mid-suffolk
councils approve the framework and that
mid-suffolk agree the sill expenditure
um that was probably an interactive
recommendation but it's actually as i
said before you are the sovereign
council so it's tonight it's just you
approving that and you're not approving
anything for for baber just to be clear
thank you councilory burn
thank you chair and thank you for that
um clarification it would be helpful if
we've had a similar clarification on the
um cifco report
which we weren't allowed to discuss
despite
being able to discuss this one
i've got a couple of points to make
though the firstly um
christine thurlow great to see you at
the briefing recently and
great to have that a really good
briefing
that um
unfortunately wasn't as well attended as
it um could have been but um i think we
all appreciated it and it was good to
have that i think for briefings in
future um
it would be great to see obviously more
people meet people there
and it's good because we can ask
questions and the team are extremely
helpful in answering those questions and
i think the issue with this is it's
quite complex and you've got parishes
and community groups trying to put bids
in and trying to work out where they're
getting their funding on and so forth
and it involves the seal team but it
also involves the communities and grants
team so we're kind of involving quite a
few people and the the more kind of
information but kind of
um
concise information we can get i think
is is is good and i think particularly
to involve um
parishes and i say parishes broadly as
in all those groups within parishes in
those briefings would be um really
really helpful um so um i i'll be
supporting this but i'll just make a
plea for for um sort of good brief
briefings as it were and concise
briefings that cover um
all of the the factors within in this to
make it easier for um
those communities to
put bids in and to
actually mitigate some of the effects of
development that they have in their
areas thank you thank you
thank you councillor eben
councillor passmore
thank you very much chairman um i'm
certainly supportive of this and i just
wanted to point out i believe i'm right
and saying that mid-suffolk and perhaps
babe at the same time we were the
original councils in suffolk that
adopted the sill going back i think for
was it five six years and there are
plenty of councils in suffolk that still
don't even have it and all i would say
is i think the way it can help with this
funding and i agree with you andrew it
is a tax on development mate no bones
about it so in the end the consumer pays
i do think it should be spread to all
houses maybe at a differential rate and
so on because clearly people live in
homes they're all going to benefit so
somehow to address that in future
would be worth looking at but i do
congratulate the team on this it's a
complicated area
we were i suppose some of the first to
start with this and it is an
evolutionary process getting greater
clarity for how it can be done i think
is very very commendable and if i
declare an interest with my hat on the
um new police and fire station in in
stone market had a considerable benefit
from that and that's exactly what peop
people want so you know if it spreads
out to sports clubs community groups and
so on which is there intended to help
them well that's really good because it
will make mid-suffolk an even more
attractive and a wonderful place to live
and work in so um well done to everybody
involved i think we're all very
appreciative of the work that's gone
into this and look forward to further
reviews and augmenting the process um as
time goes on so thanks very much
thank you councillor mansell
uh thank you chair uh i as as a member
of the joint panel um would first we'd
like to thank
uh christine and her team because
an awful lot of work goes into this uh
project and and i uh uh although it's
quite an intense uh session and we had
we had lots of meetings in a short space
of time
i welcome the opportunity to be able to
ask questions and and try and get my
head around it because it is a very
complicated um
uh field uh but i'd just like to make a
couple of uh comments on on the changes
uh i i really welcome the the bit about
the increasing the catchment areas for
some of the uh education uh transport
and health hubs and things like that
because we we need to remember that
those those health hubs don't just serve
one village they serve a whole a huge
great catchment area and we shouldn't
really just be taking the the ring fence
money from that one village where the
health hub happens to be
we need to look at where where all the
patients are coming from and make sure
because all of that development in all
the catchment area will all have an
impact on those on those hubs
and i'd also like to make a comment
about about the fact that that yes we do
need to make sure that this still money
that we're collecting gets spent as
councillor passmore has pointed out we
were one of the first councils to go for
the sill um
arrangement and our money is accruing in
the sill pot um
and we are to i think it's great that we
should be encouraging um
to be spending this money what concerns
me is that the money is being collected
because the infrastructure is needed
as the houses are built and those houses
are built and we still haven't got the
infrastructure um and yet we all know
that that money that is collected is is
not likely to be enough for all the
infrastructure that is needed from from
some of the developments so
on the one hand we want it spent now
whilst when we've got the need for the
infrastructure but we do have to bear in
mind that that all of these big big
ticket items like like rail crossings
and thurston and and schools
are going to cost an awful lot of money
and we need to make sure we've got
enough for those big items but it would
be great to have them
in a really timely manner because we
need them now we don't want them in 10
years time when we've probably got
another
800 homes
that need to feed that railway crossing
or whatever so
so yes it is good um that that we need
to encourage uh
to spend and we certainly need to be
encouraging our parishes to be using
their neighbourhood still um you know
they're getting that money uh the the
villages that have got the development
are getting their neighborhood seal
and
it needs to be spent
um
and then and then we can all
show that the residents that you know
we're getting this money and we are
doing something in our communities to
make sure that that there is some
mitigation for all of the extra
development
so thank you i will be supporting this
motion
thank you councillor richardson
thank you very much chair um a couple of
points i wanted to make and i think
actually some of it naturally quite
flows on quite nicely from uh what
councilman mansell has said um so i
think obviously just to kind of look at
this in the round one of the great
advantages of seal is that it does give
us that additional degree of flexibility
of discretion about exactly how we use
this money that is
generated by developments in our
district and i think if we're looking at
what this framework is recommending that
we change it isn't enabling us to do
even more of that in terms of that
flexibility and discretion
taking into account the new priorities
and the strategies and the focus that we
have um as a as a district um be that
from the well-being strategy from the lc
whip and you know enabling us to invest
in more open spaces more arts and
museums um and more um sort of green
infrastructure so i think that's a
really welcome uh element of part of
this and and i completely agree with
council emmanuel it's very important
that we make sure that this is done in a
broader collaborative way both in
district and without um and
the professional lead keysight's
infrastructure is already giving the
example of thurston rail is a very good
example of that and i'm sure there will
be others across the district as well so
i think in the whole i absolutely
welcome this and i think this is a
really important step forward for us in
in managing um development and actually
investing in new facilities and new um
betterment i think is the correct word
for for residents in our community so i
shall certainly be uh vote in favor of
it thank you chair
thank you councillor field
thank you there's another member of the
working party i certainly will be
supporting this and welcome the document
and would like to thank
christine and the rest of the team for
the effort they've put in
um it's interesting this working party
the effort of reconciling some quite
widely divergent views is always
interesting and amusing but has been
done successfully i think so far
um
the point i just wish to make really was
the issue of
we need to spend the money to gain the
benefit from it
uh one of the prime set of people who
are not doing very much is parish
councils
uh there are a couple of issues there i
think
one
that
they have some difficulty in
understanding all the details it is a
complex subject and we've agreed some
improved communication which will be
good to see
another issue does i i suppose i ran
into this week
probably not for the first time some
small parish councils
are
very concerned that they have to raise
cash to
carry out feasibility studies or design
studies before
they can put in a sill bid
and i certainly have one small one that
is quite concerned that
for
a modification to a village hall which
is highly gigantic
they have a severe risk of actually
going bankrupt or certainly of
taxing their financial limits so i think
although this is a good move forward
there are still some issues that the
working party
needs to discuss possibly for revision
at a subsequent round
um recognizing that while we don't want
to cover
vast amounts of feasibility studies and
finish up delivering nothing for any of
them
there is an issue there for small bodies
small village hall committees etc in
finding cash
to carry out those studies and those
bodies may not be in
possession of neighbourhood seal
themselves they may be looking at
taking advantage of sill that's been
generated in the wider area
so those comments i'll certainly support
this
recommendation thank you
councilman matheson
thank you chair yes i i i mean i i
absolutely welcome the the introduction
of seal
um
you know having spent quite a number of
years working with the the section 106
variation of it
of um getting money out of developers
and so on uh and because it offers much
greater flexibility to to alleviate
you know long-standing problems in some
some cases if you're going to make that
problem worse well
we can spend some money to make it
better instead and
all that's been that's been that's been
great
and
i think it's also the reviews and the
fourth review i mean the reviews are
very welcome because
they
they are
regular
opportunities for for the panel to to
actually listen to what members and and
then parishes as
through members are saying uh and
adapting it and you know that's that's
been great as well especially you know
the point about them that you know that
highway projects used to be rigorously
excluded and now
in various ways that they are
included and that's great as well i
think
the
the problem and i certainly support
support what's put forward absolutely
but the the problem i think we have
particulars as elected councillors
especially as district councillors and
especially those of us on the planning
committees
is is that the public
perception
is
that the you know the shortcomings and
people say well you know we're getting
more houses and where's the
infrastructure and where's the
infrastructure and they will talk about
particularly they will mean the roads
and of course we can't actually deal
with that directly
um necessarily yes not through seal
and um
and and i think even even more
particularly and difficult
is all right there's a big part of my i
was amazed to see quite how large the
pot pot now is
um
and yeah we desperately need that
being spent now
as the houses are filled up with people
and particularly i want to refer to the
health sector
and the you know the health sector seems
to say well we can't get the doctors so
basically very little happens
to
you know to address the fact that there
are more and more people and i
just don't know how exactly we can
persuade
the the nhs in its current structure to
um you know really to to get stuck into
it's better enough it was good to hear
hear from from the the officer about the
um you know engagement together with the
five-year um five-year working plans um
good
you know some of that needs to turn into
into action which the public can see
happening 30 seconds sooner rather than
later thank you chair thank you
councillor
thank you chair two completely separate
points i'd like to make
the first is i think we need to find a
way to get community groups in villages
together because there are some villages
some parishes that have got quite large
sums of money in their sill reserves
and if we can find a way i mean i know
as you know we can do our best as ward
members but with the help of officers
and with promoting sill we can get the
get the people within the parishes
together so that and i think there's a
real value to a pip in those sorts of
situations
because it it makes the different
community groups plan the future of the
village um to leave it to the parish
council
i think we will ensure that the projects
that get put forward and forget cell
funds will be the parish council
projects they may not be the village
project so i think we need to find a way
to do that
and the other the other thing we need to
be concerned about is that
in some instances
a self-funded strategic project
leads to the need for other
infrastructure for instance a new school
may well lead to a need for for
pedestrian provision for cycle provision
might even lead to the need for
road improvements so we must make sure
that we're not
using our sale money to help with one
infrastructure solution and causing an
infrastructure problem
and i think that's something we need to
bear in mind thank you
thank you very much any further
comments for debate
i'll go to um councillor burn now to sum
up
well that's a big ask german um because
we've covered quite a quite a lot of
ground here i hope most of it well at
least we can all look back on it in the
in the recording and and and get the
message i hope too that christine's been
taking a few notes because we'll need to
be discussing this at some length
afterwards
but i take i take your points i think
they're all very well made this this is
an amazing
uh
uh
an
amazing scheme that does uh produce
great results i think um
yes it would be good to spend more
um
okay
we need uh bids to make that happen
and to make the bids we need the
communities to understand
that they're there to be made and that
they can make them
so
the publicity needs improving uh i take
um councillor fields points very much to
heart
but um
i i think we can all agree it sounds to
me as though we're all all agreeing that
these uh amendments that we've made
these uh
uh changes that we've brought brought
about to the to the scheme are a step in
the right direction and i hope you will
all support them thank you very much
thank you councillor bern and i'd like
to take this to the vote now so i'll ask
the corporate manager governance and
civic office to conduct the electronic
votes thank you chair that vote is now
showing in blue for councillors to cost
their vote
chair that is unanimously full
thank you very much that's carried now
at this point we're an hour and a half
into the meeting i don't know if anybody
wants to have a five minute break i can
see another i'll take one nod as we'll
take a five minute break
so um if you could if you could be back
in five minutes that would
foreign
thank you very much welcome back
everyone
go on to item 15 now
mc2216
baber
bms sdc sustainable travel vision and
local cycling and walk-in infrastructure
plan the lc whip
i'd like to invite councillor fleming to
introduce paper
mc2216
the recommendations for this are for
noting only
thank you thank you very much chairman
thank you let me see if i can read my
report without my glasses but i can't so
i'll have to
put them on and you all look a little
bit blurry so that's just how it is
well i'm delighted to introduce this
paper i think this elsi whip is just a
really exciting
document it's more than a document it's
a whole program of how we're going to
improve transport and health and
well-being in the district
the sustainable travel vision and
associated lc whip together represent
our approach for promoting and expanding
cycling and walking
the vision recognizes the value of these
modes of transport
and also that residents will still need
cars for certain jerseys
the intention is to make it easier
safer and more pleasant for those who
already walk and cycle for whatever
reasons
and to prompt those who may be
considering it to give it a try
the lc whip is a national government
recommended tool
promoted by the department for transport
which is being taken up
by us and by neighboring councils as
well as the county and in norfolk
its key function is to enable potential
routes
to be prioritized for purposes of
assessing their viability
and their need and purpose so that we're
ready to bid for funds and enter into
partnerships as opportunities arise
the three key outputs of the lc whip are
a prioritized program of infrastructure
improvements a network plan
for walking and cycling
which identifies prefer routes
and a report which sets out the analysis
of the roots
the list of roots in our lc whip
reflects a successful consultation held
last year that received over eighteen
hundred public responses
that's really impressive
the initial list has been reviewed and
assessed based on the dft scoring
mechanism
adjusted slightly to reflect our
district's rural landscape
and agreed by a cross-party working
group
the prioritization is subject to
re-analysis
and potentially to change as new
information becomes available
i would like to stress that the lc whip
is and will remain a living dynamic
document
as the schemes within it are examined in
more detail
this process will uncover opportunities
for funding and support which may have
been missed
and i may identify partners that may
wish to be involved such as potential
employers or cycling or walking clubs
this is the first version and my guess
is that the list will change quite soon
and finally
the list of schemes is long and the
outcome of hope and optimism
however the difficulties of delivering
them are substantial and expensive
and i don't wish to get hopes up to an
unreasonable
level all members are encouraged to
examine the list and discuss with their
parishes and local communities and seek
further detail and identify local issues
which could
which could help to deliver them
and in conclusion
i would like to thank both the public
for their active engagement and officers
for their hard work
looking at catherine there
on this very important project thank you
thank you councillor fleming we will now
move to questions would anyone like to
ask a question
councillor ebern
thank you chair thank you for that
councillor fleming just a quick one um
bearing in mind the previous paper and
the fact that putting together the lc
whip um is looking
when it is making us in a position where
if funding opportunities are available
then we've got the evidence to go for
that are we going to actually allocate a
certain amount of district sill to the
elsi whip project so that we're already
prepped for that position thank you
that's the council of fleming
um
i can i think i can say with this
reasonable degree of certainty that we
aren't allocating funds per se but that
still funds
will be available on a case-by-case
basis um perhaps i can be
corrected by officers on that point
the director for economic development
who's going to take this yeah
the director for economic development
thank you
um thank you and
i i think um councillor fleming is
correct in that we will
not specifically
sum of money allocated from sill but
more as they come forward um i think the
challenge for us is uh ensuring that we
can get schemes to a point where they
are suitable for bidding into sill so
some early feasibility work needs to be
done on each of the schemes to ensure
that we can make seal bids
any further questions council welum
thank you chair um i've been looking at
the
list of schemes in
mid-suffolk and unfortunately the
the link is www.baber.gov.uk
given in the report
is there not some way that when we
publicize this
in
mid-suffolk that we can have a
mid-suffolk link not via
www.baber.gov
um because it i i think we're more
likely to get our parishes in
mid-suffolk to look at it if it's not a
labour document so is that something we
can sort out please
the sustainable travel officer
thank you yes that link may have just
been used in the cabinet report but
there is a mid-suffolk link to the same
sustainable travel webpage on the
mid-suffolk website and that will be
used when we write to our parishes in
suffolk thank you
any further questions
no well we'll move to um debate now um
same rules apply who would like to start
councillor eben
um thank you chair and thank you
councillor fleming for this paper and
particularly thank you to um the officer
catherine for all the hard work she's
done in this and i just want to stress
that this particular project is one that
i'm sure we'll all agree that so many of
our communities have got very
enthusiastic about and so many people
have responded to the original
consultation
which was really heartening to see and i
just think it's beholden now on us to
make sure that things happen from it
because i've i've not you know we've had
such a lot of questions and interest
from the community so i would really
like to see that we can make sure that
we take things forward from this but
thank you again to particularly to the
officer involved thank you chair
thank
you any
councillor mansell
uh uh thank you chair um i i'd just like
to echo what um uh councillor ebern has
said uh and clearly this is a project
very close to my heart
and i think it is fantastic that we now
have an lc whip and i'm really hoping
that
the the very fact that we've now got the
lc whip uh kathryn has done a lot of
work on this and i think it's great
um that we are able to access funds not
just through our own cell funds
and i really think that that that what
we need now i mean this this is so
all-encompassing because if we can
deliver a scheme
that um you know
not not i mean i'm not i think we need
to actually
deliver a scheme that that is going to
um that we can then use as an example to
show the communities what we can do
if we can
i don't know upgrade a footpath and and
enable more children to walk to school
it would be just such a fantastic
centerpiece of achievement that we are
doing with something really positive
about getting the modal shift because we
all hear complaints about traffic around
schools and the parking every village
has got the same issue about parents
parking outside schools now if we can
link one of our lc whip projects that we
can actually deliver
and enable more people to safely walk to
school we can maybe alleviate some of
those other issues
and the other thing that i really hope
that we can get out of this project is
we can influence uh planning decisions
about sustainable travel
and make sure that we have all those
connect all that connectivity for
pedestrians and cyclists from one
development to the other into the town
centers
so that we are really enabling people i
mean i know it's a long shot to get
people to change their ways but if we
can just do something small that will
actually encourage more people to get
out of their cars and walk it will just
be fantastic so thank you very much for
the officers who've worked on this thank
you very much to all the members of the
public who put into that consultation
which was lovely lovely map-based
consultation i just think that the next
stage is is going to be crucial we've
got to deliver a scheme and we've got to
show some difference so
let's hope we can get there thank you
thank you councillor parker well thank
you chairman just very briefly what a
wonderful acronym an lc wick i wonder
what that was i had to check it but
i thought i've had enough acronyms um to
last me a lifetime but that's a new one
on me but no seriously i think it's a
really good idea and all i can say is
encouraging um certainly children to get
on their bike and go to school is a very
good idea it's actually quite good for
them i used to cycle the school four
miles there and funnily enough four
miles back because i got so fed up with
my dad uh making me let me get into
trouble getting
detention because of him but on a
serious point given the opportunity for
people to do that not only is it um
um a good thing to do it's actually good
for the individual to keep them fit and
toughen them up so i think there are
other benefits as well so um but i don't
think i'll be getting on a cycle lane
all the way from tweet down to endeavour
house which is about 10 17 18 miles and
17 or 18 miles back but um but there we
are and certainly not in the heat of the
last few days but now well done and
thank you very much for doing this i
think we're all right behind it
thank you very much
anyone else
any comments
no okay thank you very much councillor
fleming would you like to add anything
at this stage
um
i'll just just say again a big thank you
to everyone who's participated in this
and also i'd like to say this is the
beginning it's it's by no means a
concluded um program we're starting on
something and it's going to go on
indefinitely i hope and
the schemes will some of them will take
time so i think it needs patience and
dedication to to achieve what we all
want so thank you all very much
thank you councillor fleming and that
report was for noting only so we'll um
we'll move on to the motions on notice
and um councillor mellon would you like
to move your motion please
yes thank you chad um
if i just may have just a moment at the
beginning just to
uh explain uh perhaps people were
wondering why why my question earlier
about the sifko item
i was just simply trying to clarify that
uh when an item was withdrawn close to a
meeting
every member should hear at the same
time so that we don't spend too much
time uh
reading the papers um but i think that
point has now been made and we'll move
on
turning to the motion
um mr chairman we hear a lot in the news
about retrofitting at the moment
and i know we all know what this means
making homes
more energy efficient by putting in
insulation
improving doors and windows and also
installing renewable energy measures
solar panels maybe a storage battery
perhaps an air source or a ground source
heat pump
and while some homes in mid-suffolk are
already well insulated and energy
efficient many are not
and so a big effort is needed over the
next few years if we are to meet our
countries and our counties aspirations
to reach net zero
and of course the wonderful thing about
retrofitting is that it achieves
multiple objectives we have warmer homes
in winter cooler homes in summer and
people lifted out of fuel poverty we
have lower carbon dioxide emissions the
emissions slashed and everyone on the
planet benefits
and also
it can create long-lasting and quality
green jobs
now members will remember i'm sure that
at last month's council meeting we
debated the hra business plan which
included a 30-year plan for retrofitting
our own council houses
and this is all well and good but as we
saw
the pace of retrofitting activity is
limited by the constraints of the hra
funding model you know the money is ring
fenced as we know and the government
rules limit how much we can borrow
but there are things we can do to shift
the balance and increase the rate at
which retrofitting happens and this is
where our motion comes in and it's a
simple one
it's encouraging a single idea that
working together across a wider area
than our two councils brings benefits
the fact is that all councils are in
pretty much the same situation we all
need to do retrofitting and often our
council homes are similar types of
construction so there are benefits to be
gained by working together and this is
what is currently being done down in
sussex where seven councils have got
together and have found a way to work
collaboratively on this issue benefiting
everyone
so why would you we do this well firstly
there are economies of scale the
councils in sussex
are aiming to work on 40 000 homes
now this number gives them enormous
buying power and economies of scale
driving down the cost for each
individual installation the power of the
market at work
secondly
the collaborative approach means that
each individual council does not need to
reinvent the wheel
in sussex working with experts from the
construction industry with academics and
architects
they identified 10 housing archetypes
and for each one the best measures for
improvement
for example a mid-terrace home built in
the 1960s with solid walls might best be
improved by fitting external insulation
cladding upgrading the windows and
putting pv panels on the roof
a detached bungalow might benefit from a
different set of measures these are just
examples but the point is this once the
best measures for each type of housing
have been broadly identified there is
much less individual design work for
each property and work can proceed at a
faster pace
thirdly a collaborative approach over a
wide area means that a consistent and
stable supply chain can be established
for both materials
skills and people
the renewable sector has really suffered
over the years from boom and bust as
government support has progressed in and
out of various schemes
you know for a while we had the feed-in
tariff scheme then that went
and it boosted the industry but then
tailed off then we had the green deal
introduced in 2013 and pulled in 2015.
a couple of years later we had the green
homes grant which is supposed to improve
600 000 homes which only reached 47 000
and was withdrawn so a consistent
long-term approach is needed to make the
retrofit industry sustainable
and to be honest this seems to be more
likely to come from the bottom up
a local authority-led initiative than
from the regular switches of direction
in westminster
lastly the benefits of getting this
right for local authority homes
can then start to spread to the private
sector
if we have people and firms with the
right skills good local suppliers
and the knowledge of what to do for each
type of housing retrofit becomes easier
and cheaper for everyone
so to sum up we think the approach being
taken in
sussex the so-called lewis model is a
good one and we bring this motion to
council and the same proposal to babel
later
in september to kick-start the process
let's get our officers look having a
look at it start talking to other local
authorities and see if we can get the
ball rolling on a similar scheme here in
suffolk
i have had discussions with councillor
morley who has proposed an amendment
which we are minded to accept in order
to get cross-party support provided that
we do get reporting back to this council
we've all seen the realities of climate
change this week in the record
temperatures we have experienced
climate scientists are telling us that
we need to act now
time is short
the opportunity is there to make a
difference so i commend this motion and
ask for members to support it thank you
thank you very much councillor mellon i
believe councillor ebern you wished a
second
um thank you chair yes i would like to
second the motion but i'd reserve my
right to speak thank you very much thank
you very much
um and there was a amendment mentioned
there would you like to speak on the
amendment counselor morley
i agree with the main premise
of the first paragraph
and while mid-suffolk has nowhere like
forty thousand
houses in our hras closer to three and a
half thousand but um
my feeling is that
mid suffolk is not the best place for
this to be
promulgated
as i'm sure you're all aware we have the
suffolk public sector leaders group
which is set up and works across suffolk
on initiatives that cover the whole of
suffolk
and this strikes me as
fitting really nicely into
that category
so
the
suffolk climate change energy and
environment board is the proper body
which sits underneath
spsl to actually discuss this rather
than
it being a mid-suffolk task
so
what i would actually like to amend the
paragraph to read is the first sentence
of the second paragraph
to become
this council agrees to ask the housing
task group
which is a subgroup of skeeb
to start dialogue with other local
authorities and external stakeholders to
investigate if a similar project could
be initiated in suffolk to improve the
pace of retrofitting so that's just the
first
sentence of that second paragraph
thank you
so is there a problem
no i'm sorry i think i missed something
from um counselor mansell
i just made the point that it's the only
sentence in the second paragraph no it's
not just the first sentence it is the
same okay well well thank you very much
do we have a um second uh
for the councillor richardson
thank you chair i'm happy to second uh
councilman morley's amendment and if
there is a debate then i would like to
reserve my right to speak thank you okay
thank you very much councillor mellon do
you accept the amendment
i'm not sure of the exact process
because it will come back to spsl
but um i don't know whether they're
monitoring this
you can help it will certainly come back
to sbsm
and
i'm happy to bring it back here
afterwards
are you
happy would you like
the chief executive
there we go i was just going to make the
same point as the leader which is we can
bring it back through through the
leader's announcements all through
variety of mechanisms be that all member
briefing whatever's most appropriate
we'll make sure councillors are aware
in that case i'm happy to accept the
amendment
thank you very much councillor even do
you accept the amendment um thank you
chair yes i'd accept the amendment right
if we can get feedback to this chamber
here or on and how that is progressing
thank you
okay thank you very much that becomes a
substantive
motion so um we'll now go into um debate
who would like to start
councilman matthewson
thank you chair yeah the um
when we talked about the hr i
previously i i
was expressing particularly frustration
about the fact that we couldn't actually
use the general fund to to um
to help
uh in various ways and the
section 151 officer did
undertake at that time to
have a look at
ways in which we might use the general
fund to for such things as as
external environmental improvements you
know sort of landscaping and that kind
of thing which
was being spent from the hra but could
legitimately be taken from general fund
and so i think in this context i'd be
you know it's unfortunate that that the
one final officer is not here but i
think i wanted to
you know repeat that question and the
need to look at that
um in in within this um discussion as
well
and um so i i
don't suppose councillor whitehead's got
an answer um to hand but um anyway i i i
bring that question back
for an answer sometime please
um
we may be able to help
um
get projects like this i do wonder
whether the the substance of the
of the motion um
is
is something that must come the money
any costs must come from within the hra
but again that's probably one five one
um
questions that we can
hear hear about subsequently perhaps
as a sort of written answer or something
thank you very much councillor mansell
thank you i i welcome this motion and i
i welcome the whatever it was called
long-winded name about something to do
with environment on the suffolk public
sector leaders group or whatever they're
called lots of acronyms there but i
can't remember what they were
i i'd just like to to to um make a
comment on on what the chief executive
said a few minutes ago
when he said that yes it would be
reported back uh possibly through the
leaders announcements um my issue with
the leaders announcements is that we're
not allowed to ask questions or discuss
anything so i would really like that
when this does come back it is in it is
in some forum where we are allowed to
ask questions and we are allowed to
discuss it
and question things thank you
thank you very much
any
anyone else
counselor richardson
thank you very much chair um just a
couple of points i think i'd make uh in
so as council mali sort of indicated
we're um on this side of the chamber
happy to support this motion um i think
fundamentally the principle behind this
makes perfect sense um i think we are
one of our strengths as a council is
that we actually are very good at our
broader partnership working across the
system whether that's through spsl
shared revenues partnership shared legal
services gateway home choice etc etc
and i think fundamentally given the
challenges of the hra i think um
working more collaboratively with with
the rest of our partners in terms of
retrofitting social housing
is fundamentally a good idea um one just
point i will make though which is part
of the reason why we've amended this
ever so slightly to omit um the
researching of this motion is in the
time that uh it was published uh between
the time it was published and now our
officers have done so um and well they
couldn't find much
but it did cause them a little bit of
confusion so there's apparently it seems
nothing on the lewis council website
about this model um the only reference
they can find is from a blog post by a
lewis councillor on something called
green world
but what they think they what what they
found is that this relates to something
called the greater brighton retrofit
task force and we're assuming the same
thing it references the same number of
houses the same number of uh district
councils now apparently according to
what they found this was set up on the
20th of july last year it was due to
present an initial report back in uh
this spring of this year but hasn't done
so
and i'll just and the reason i want to
just make this point is i think it's
worth just setting expectations very
clear about what it is we're looking
into and therefore what potential
outcomes we may get so if i just quote
from the officer who invested who did
some looking into this on our behalf he
said that i haven't been able to find
anything that says how this money has
been pulled its governance etc i don't
even know if it's one billion pounds
which is the figure quoted it's in the
pot now or is a commitment over a number
of years uh the claim is that that
amount of money that they can generate
through economies of scale
but again i haven't found anything that
puts a number to those savings
so i think it's worth just clarifying
that because while we're happy with the
principle of this motion
and
what i will just say is i think the
approach as a whole is absolutely fine
but we must be really clear that what
we're actually
doing is just looking into this broader
approach um and this this collaboration
through spsl and its subsidiary bodies
because we can't research the lewis
model because we can't find anything
that says exists and we can't research
really this task force because it hasn't
done anything
so i think we're happy with the
principle but i don't think there's
anything that we can find that provides
more detail about this than what is in
the motion so i think what we're saying
is we're happy to look into this further
but we should be really clear about what
exactly we hope to gain from this thank
you chair
thank you very much
anybody
councillor wella
thank you chad i mean just a few words
i'll be supporting this motion i think
we all know that
urgent action on reducing the energy use
in homes is needed
so i think it's important that our
leader encourages other leaders
to make sure make it clear that this is
urgent and that it isn't something just
to be put on the shelf thank you
thank you councillor stringer
thank you uh i will be supporting this
motion unsurprisingly because we
actually have to get this moving and it
has to be
get moving pretty sharpish because we
were coming from a long way back we
probably should have been doing this
about six seven years ago probably a
decade ago
uh
that said we are where we are or where
we choose to be and we choose to be
right here right now and we can actually
do something about this and we need to
uh
some people might ask why us why do we
need to do this if you go back to the
foundation of district councils as why
we're here does anybody anyone know why
we're actually here we were here and we
were set up to deal with sewage
because there was rampant development
all sorts of different standards on how
you got the nasty stuff out of houses
and new factories etc and no one was
prepared
to take responsibility for it and there
wasn't an honest broker that could pull
the funds from various developers to
connect up to proper sewage works that's
where local authorities came from in the
first instance
and and it's probably a pretty good
metaphor for what we need to do now yeah
they were in the nasty stuff then if
they didn't get it right and i think
we're in the nasty stuff now if we don't
get this right
and who else is going to do it
because it needs to be done at the
current level
we do fund retrofitting some people's
homes in here in the whole suffolk we do
about 300 homes a year
from
what is called a green levy on the
electricity bill
that's highly likely to disappear in the
next few months according to what i'm
seeing in the media so even that
300 homes a year in the whole of suffolk
could well be challenged
at that current rate to deliver all the
homes we need to deliver in suffolk
that are in this sector it probably
takes 100 years we haven't got a hundred
years
we need this to pull the expertise a lot
of expertise is in this council
we also need to make sure that we train
a labor force to do this we desperately
need to get this done so anything that
initiates that first
step needs to have all speed uh
and all luck frankly so i will be
supporting this motion
uh if if nothing else to make sure that
we don't end up in the nasty stuff later
down the line thank you thank you very
much councillor fleming
yes thank you very much i just want to
briefly explain why i will be abstaining
on this motion
whereas i
as you probably know
support the sentiment behind it we've
had a number of different um suggestions
and motions brought um by our very
well-meaning opposition but i think the
problem is they don't all come together
in a coherent fashion
and they really need to and i realize
there are a lot of different groups and
organizations within the county all
trying to do more or less the same thing
for instance the
suffolk environment cabinet
members group is looking at a um
you know a similar program suffer
to be built into a suffolk wide
design um
policy and we're looking at this and we
need to look this at this coherently and
i don't see this as being the right
avenue for doing what i think we all
would like to do
thank you
thank you very much councillor eppinyon
thank you mr chairman um
i mean i think this motion
is deserving of
our support but i i do think that
we need to be a little bit careful
because
councillor mellon talks about the lose
model
and in my experience a model is
something that someone has created
executed tried out and proven how it
works
the lose model is not one of those
things
i quote the counsellor from sussex
saying the lose model is an ambitious
plan
well that's great
we are about doing things here in mid
software and in suffolk generally and
whilst i agree that we should go ahead
and investigate
the the way that we can pull resources
to do this i would just remind everyone
that actually we are doing our bit in
mid mid-suffolk in terms of what we can
do in terms of renovating our properties
but yes let's go ahead and and actually
let's develop a suffolk model that works
and then lose can follow us thank you
thank you very much
um
councillor eben you've reserved your
right to speak would you like to um
say anything further before council
mellon sums up
i would chair thank you very much
um
firstly um if anyone would like some
phone numbers of people to call to talk
about this i'm happy to provide them
um
but i think um
yes we want to do our bit
and
often we hear in this council about
ambition
and we often hear about miss suffolk
setting example a suffolk leading the
way and we often get up and say with
pride
from whichever side of the of the
chamber that we have um others have
followed our lead
here we are again here's an idea others
can follow our lead others can help work
on it if we produce a suffolk model or
well and good but i think ultimately we
have an ambition to see our council's
housing stock improved for our tenants
benefits more comfortable to live in
cheaper bills and better future proofed
but we all know the constraints of the
housing budget within the rule set by
government and this means it's difficult
to achieve and could take many years
additionally
we know that there is a need for more
homes in general to be insulated to be
updated and can we not help enable this
private sector tenants for example how
are we helping them in this in this in
this arena
so
what we're looking at is
looking into something that is happening
working with other councils achieving
economies of scale using local suppliers
utilizing low carbon materials and
improving homes
so if you just look at the number of
homes just taking council homes per se
we've got about 3200 in mid-suffolk out
of 41 000 homes
so just looking at council homes that's
about eight percent
in suffolk there are 350 000 homes eight
percent of that is about twenty eight
thousand pounds twenty hundred pounds
twenty eight thousand homes
that is a significant number and that is
just the sort of social housing elements
it doesn't take into account the private
rented sector those people with homes
that might want to improve them and have
just been looking for something some
kind of scheme somewhere where you can
actually use local suppliers where
there's a their confidence something
that's backed by their local council not
necessarily backed with finance but
backed in terms of we've looked into
this we've found suppliers we've used
low carbon materials here you are off
you go
and i think we can be the inspiration
for a massive impact across suffolk
so yes what it does need is a dialogue
across
different parts of the county and
we really do need to kind of get on with
this and do something and this is just
something positive to look into with
regards to the work that the suffolk
climate change environment and energy
board are doing they've got
one two three four projects on the go to
do with housing at the last
minutes i was able to find so and this
isn't one of those so other other areas
have got seven eight projects let's ask
them to have a look at this and thank
you councillor morley for your amendment
and i think it'll be useful for them to
to look at this and i look forward to
hearing back positively and i hope that
you will all support this thank you
chair
thank you very much councillor eben
councillor mellon would you like to add
anything
yes thank you chair
um
the area of retrofitting is such an
important area if we are to meet our
environment environmental ambitions that
we've all signed up to
it is an area that needs innovation
in fact it's crying out for innovation
and we've brought forward this proposal
as something we could look at
i do hear councillor richardson's
caution
but that is why the motion is in the
area of investigation looking at the
ideas and seeing what merit there is
i'm disappointed that some counselors do
not feel they can fully support the
motion in actual fact the ask is pretty
small
as councillorette penang has said we are
doing our bit
this motion simply brings forward an
idea that could help us to do more and i
do commend it to members thank you
thank you very much
um i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if you could cost your votes
sorry
some reason the voting facility isn't
opening but i'm voting in favor of the
motion
um
chair that is 25 4 and 3 abstentions
thank you very much and that's carried
so we'll go on to item 18 councillor
appointments are there any changes to
placings
no no
okay so um with that i'll um
i'll
inform you that the date of the next
meeting is thursday the 22nd of
september
at 5 30
and i'll finish the meeting
at 7 45
thank you very much everyone
you